[Musica]
buonasera buonasera
ma grazie almeno vi ascolto perché non
li vedo molto per me molto importante di
solito avere uno scambio visivo comunque
immaginiamo un albero e da questo albero
accade una foglia questa foglia viene
portata dal vento e portata dal vento
cade per terra in una posizione precisa
una posizione che non è né un centimetro
e la né un centimetro in qua quella
posizione ii e dinanzi a questo ci
chiediamo ma perché quella foglia è
accaduta esattamente lì e non un
centimetro in qua un centimetro in là
perché è caduta esattamente lì e le
polizie delle possibilità che mi vengono
in mente sono praticamente due o è una
ragione aleatoria o invece la posizione
della foglia è perfetta perfetta intesa
che dinanzi a tutte le cause condizioni
che sono avvenute non poteva essere
diversa la posizione in quella nella
quale quella follia caduta è stata
influenzata dal vento dalla temperatura
dalla pressione atmosferica dal bambino
che giocava per terra che con il pallone
ha picchiato l'albero in quel momento
dall insetto che mangio cava il ramo da
infinite variabili che hanno portato
quella foglia accadere esattamente in
quel posto lì perciò se noi ci chiediamo
la posizione in cui quella follia caduta
e aleatoria o è perfetta in realtà dal
mio punto di vista è perfetta non perché
non possa avere magari dei conflitti o
sarebbe meglio se fosse da un'altra
parte
ma dinanzi a tutto ciò che è accaduto
così come accaduto non poteva essere
diverso
chi non sia questo io mi chiedo io sono
perfetto direi di sì voi siete perfetti
direi di sì questo non vuol dire che non
abbiamo i nostri conflitti non abbiamo
le nostre sofferenze non abbiamo i
nostri problemi problemi e tutto il
resto che conosciamo bene ma vuol dire
che quello che noi siamo oggi la nostra
vita la nostra situazione fisica
familiare lavorativa sociale in tutti
gli aspetti della nostra vita
sono così perché ci sono state infinite
cause condizioni che hanno lavorato fra
di loro in una complessa interazione che
da portato ad essere ciò che quindi
quante volte non siamo trovati davanti
una persona magari abbiamo detto la
persona ma tu non dovresti essere così o
quante volte che qualcuno non è venuto
da noi e ci ha detto ma guarda ma tu non
dovresti essere così un genitore verso i
fili o viceversa
però la realtà è che se qualcuno viene
da noi ci dice ma tu non dovresti essere
così cosa rispondiamo finisca ci possono
così perché sono così ma come mai siamo
così come mai siamo qui oggi perché ci
sono stati pensieri scelte interazioni
luoghi che siamo andati immagini che
abbiamo visto che ci hanno portato ad
essere oggi qui in questo momento perciò
quello che siamo
non è una realtà un risultato aleatorio
ma il risultato di infiniti piccole cose
che gradualmente si sono relazionate fra
di loro
noi oggi siamo influenzati da esperienze
che abbiamo avuto quando eravamo bambini
che vanno a determinare le nostre scelte
anche nel momento presente e dinanzi a
questo nasce una domanda che la domanda
ma
lo abbiamo in libertà siamo veramente
liberi di scegliere di agire o no io ho
riflettuto su questo tante volte la
conclusione che sono arrivato è che il
momento presente in cui noi ci troviamo
e di conseguenza la nostra persona il
nostro carattere il nostro corpo le
nostre conoscenze il nostro modo di
pensare
le nostre emozioni e quindi delle scelte
che facciamo sono fortemente
profondamente influenzati dalle
esperienze che abbiamo avuto
ma le persone che abbiamo incontrato dai
pensieri che abbiamo avuto dalle scelte
che abbiamo fatto da ogni momento della
nostra vita
quindi il momento presente è fortemente
condizionato da tutto ciò che è avvenuto
addirittura le scelte che noi facciamo
che crediamo di essere totalmente liberi
sono fortemente influenzate e
condizionate da tutte le esperienze
passate che abbiamo vissuto dal contesto
culturale sociale e tutto il resto
e dinanzi a questo può venire un
pensiero che ma o libertà o no è una
volta proprio parlavo di questo in
brasile piegavo il fatto che quando noi
ci vediamo un'altra persona e diciamo ma
se io fossi in te avrei fatto così ma ma
se io fossi in te col tuo corpo con le
tue esperienze con la tua mente con la
tua cultura con i tuoi traumi con le tue
conoscenze farei diversamente o
probabilmente farei comet e
probabilmente farei come te è una volta
dopo aver parlato di tutto questo
incontro due giorni dopo in un
ristorante un signore che era stato in
quel momento mi dice guarda tu sei stato
bravissimo a spiegare come nessun altro
prima che in realtà non abbiamo libero
arbitrio bellissimo ma come se la base
per me è il fatto che siamo liberi nella
questa scelta è quello mi ha fatto
riflettere tanto quindi quanta libertà
abbiamo effettivamente a usando una
metafora che non mi piace tantissimo
però che in qualche modo funziona bene
la metafora del poter comprare qualcosa
siamo liberi di comprare ciò che
vogliamo o no a principio si dinanzi a
due fattori
dobbiamo avere i soldi e ciò che
vogliamo comprare deve essere in vendita
perché se io voglio comprare qualcosa
che non è in vendita
non lo posso comprare così come se vuole
comprare qualcosa che in vendita ma per
il quale non ho i soldi non lo posso
comprare perciò noi siamo liberi di
scegliere e di agire nella nostra vita
però siamo condizionati da tutto ciò che
abbiamo vissuto e fatto finora siamo
condizionati dal nostro passato nel
momento presente in cui noi viviamo
perciò non abbiamo in grado di scelta
molto ampio secondo me se noi dovessimo
vedere la nostra libertà e come mezzo
grado fra 360
però quel mezzo grado sommandosi uno
all'altro e portando avanti può portare
delle differenze enormi la nostra
libertà si trova nel dire o non dire
fare o non fare manifestare un pensiero
un sentimento o non manifestarlo andare
o non andare sono nelle piccole azioni
quotidiane nelle piccole scelte dove si
trova effettivamente la nostra realtà la
nostra libertà
noi non siamo liberi di essere qualcosa
che immaginiamo siamo liberi di agire
con piccole azioni per gradualmente
diventare qualcosa che possiamo
desiderare una cosa che in questi
momenti che stiamo vivendo io ho potuto
constatare sulla mia pelle
che questo momento di lotta un di caos
che grandi eventi non creano grandi
cambiamenti
i cambiamenti avvengono tramite le
piccole scelte quotidiane che andiamo a
fare tramite quelle piccole azioni e
verso i cambiamenti come se ci potesse
andare verso un cambiamento in realtà
noi tutti noi stiamo costantemente in
cambiamento non abbiamo la scelta di
cambiare o non cambiare di trasformarci
o non trasformarci però abbiamo la
seguente scelta se vogliamo trasformarci
come un semplice risultato è una
semplice reazione di ciò che ci accade
nella nostra vita o se vogliamo
trasformarci con consapevolezza verso un
obiettivo verso una direzione scelta
questo è qualcosa che possiamo
effettivamente fare nella nostra vita ci
sono principalmente tre forze che
guidano le nostre azioni
il passato il presente e il futuro
molto spesso quando abbiamo un emozione
e quando di conseguenza andiamo a dire
qualcosa a fare una scelta a manifestare
quel sentimento interagire con il mondo
facciamo ciò che facciamo come se quello
fosse una conseguenza di ciò che è
avvenuto
sono arrabbiato perché mi hai detto
questo sono invidioso perché è successo
qua l'altro io dico questo perché mi è
successo quella cosa faccio questo
perché è accaduto quell'altro
molto spesso le scelte che noi prendiamo
nel momento presente sono condizionate
da ciò che è accaduto nel nostro passato
un'altra forza è il presente nella quale
noi andiamo ad agire come una semplice
reazione a ciò che sta accadendo nel
momento presente
mi piace attrazione non mi piace
avversione
però la forza principale che deve
direzionarsi nella nostra vita è in
realtà il futuro
noi non dobbiamo agire oggi come una
conseguenza di ciò che è avvenuto ieri
ma io devo agire oggi come una causa per
ciò che voglio diventare io non devo
agire sulla base di ciò che sono
massi sulla base di ciò che voglio
diventare prendiamo un esempio pratico
le relazioni interpersonali qualunque
relazione sia essa con un padre con la
madre con i fili
una relazione che può essere di coppia
qualunque relazione che sia pensate una
riusciamo a immaginare come vorrei che
quella relazione fosse vorrei che fosse
una relazione basata sulla fiducia e sul
rispetto che ci fosse gratitudine che o
non riuscissi ad accettare l'altro e
allo stesso tempo aiutare uno all'altro
ad essere una persona migliore
vorrei che ci fosse pazienza vorrei che
ci fosse tanto amore tanto affetto
io vorrei abbiamo una relazione così
però nella vita quotidiana succede che a
un certo punto uno è nervoso succede
qualcosa eccetera e reagisce male e
quando l'altro reagisce male nei miei
confronti
qual è la mia tendenza essere paziente
amorevole o reagire nello stesso modo la
nostra tendenza è quella di reagire però
a questo punto io vado ad agire come un
risultato di ciò che è avvenuto ma se
quello che io voglio e costruire una
relazione di fiducia di amore eccetera
io devo agire con amore con rispetto con
fiducia perché è nel momento presente
che io vado a costruire il mio futuro è
una delle forze principali che esiste
nella nostra vita e il desiderio e
l'altra forza è la versione di una delle
cose fondamentali per tutti
noi che va al di là della religione o no
nel buddismo e molto importante però va
al di là di tutto questo è una domanda
molto semplice cosa voglio e cosa non
voglio ma non solo al momento presente
anche guardando verso il futuro
io vi invito a fare una riflessione di
riuscire a immaginare chi voglio essere
io al di là della mia apparenza esterna
al di là del mio contesto sociale al di
là dell'aspetto materiale
voglio essere una persona soddisfatta o
insoddisfatta voglio avere più rispetto
più gratitudine più amore più
soddisfazione più gioia
voglio vivere con più rabbia gelosia
invidia rancore paura ansia una domanda
se noi riusciamo a immaginare chi voglio
essere dinanzi a quello dobbiamo
cominciare ad agire nella nostra
quotidianità per diventare facciamo un
esempio pratico anche perché il tempo
che abbiamo è poco
una delle caratteristiche fondamentali
per la nostra felicità e la
soddisfazione
uno degli aspetti che porta tanta
sofferenza e l'insoddisfazione più mi
lamento più critico più insoddisfatto
sono e di conseguenza più soffro più
ringrazio più riggio isco più
soddisfatto sono e quindi esiste una
cosa pratica non criticare non
lamentarsi viene vuole di lamentarsi
viene volete criticare morde la lingua
stai zitto ma per una semplice ragione
ogni volta che io agisco tramite un
sentimento come l'insoddisfazione io
vado a rinforzare quel sentimento
ogni volta che quel sentimento sorge e
io non l'ho blocco e non lo seguo prima
o poi finisce e si indebolisce
quindi io vi invito a ragionare un po a
osservare a riflettere nella vita di
tutti i giorni
la se stesso chi voglio essere cosa
voglio sviluppare dentro di me e
dobbiamo agire quotidianamente di
conseguenza
in altre parole se voglio essere una
persona altruista perché comprendo che
egoisticamente parlando è meglio essere
altruisti e meglio essere un altruista
artificiale che un egoista naturale
perché se lo faccio con sincerità
gradualmente lo diventò quindi o invito
ognuno a mettere uno sforzo nella vita
di tutti i giorni per parlare e agire e
pensare secondo ciò che vogliamo essere
e non come una reazione di ciò che è
avvenuto
volevo concludere con una frase che mi
accompagna sempre perché la vita passa
in fretta veramente passo in fretta
pensiamo di fare le cose passano la
frase in tibetano dice ceco ceco sun
news on my two much un samnin hewson h
casa mission che torna nell'uomo cruccio
lo mise pompa se ben ambrì l'italiano
sarebbe qualcosa come pensando di fare
pensando di fare son passati vent'anni
non sono riuscito non sono riuscito son
passati vent'anni a perché non ho fatto
a perché non ho fatto sono passati
vent'anni così alla biografia così son
passati sessant'anni
questa è la biografia di una vita vuota
se c'è qualcosa che riteniamo che si
importante nella nostra vita dobbiamo
farlo oggi senza scuse perché così
costruiamo il nostro futuro
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]